هذه هي الطريقة التي انتهى بها يوم إحياء ذكرى
انفجار المحكمة الرابعة في أغسطس / آب الاشتباكات بين
المتظاهرين وقوات الأمن اللبنانية
المتواجدة في
أسفل الشارع وعلى مقربة منها ،
هذه هي أكبر
الاحتجاجات التي شهدناها منذ الأيام التي
أعقبت الانفجار.
في العام الماضي ووفقًا للصليب الأحمر اللبناني
، أصيب عشرات الأشخاص بالفعل ، وهذا حقًا
نتيجة لهذا الغضب
العميق للعديد من اللبنانيين من النخبة
الحاكمة ، أدت النخبة الحاكمة التي أساءت إدارة
الاقتصاد
إلى انهيار اقتصادي ومالي.
أنه نتيجة لإهمالها
، فساد وسوء الإدارة
لتفجير بيروت قبل عام
اليوم
والذي أودى بحياة أكثر من 200 شخص وجرح
أكثر من 6000 وشرد 300000
شخص
الآن ،
كان هذا فندقًا فاخرًا في يوم من الأيام
ولكن بسبب الاضطرابات
هنا تم تغطيته بالكامل
بالفولاذ ولكن هؤلاء الأشخاص
يقرعون الجدران لمجرد إظهار
غضبهم وعدم رضاهم عن
التكرار وهنا لدينا المزيد من
الغاز المسيل للدموع المتطاير في
هذا يؤكد حقًا فشل
النظام السياسي اللبناني في تلبية الاحتياجات
الأساسية للشعب ، وبالتالي فإن
رد فعل الناس بهذه الطريقة أنا بن ويدوم وسي إن إن
التقارير من بيروت.